Hurricane Florence is making landfall
after thrashing the Carolinas all night
long with devastating flooding and
damaging winds forecasters are warning
that Florence's storm surge is
life-threatening and will be even worse
at high tide later this morning the
center of Florence is near Wilmington
North Carolina with maximum sustained
winds of 90 miles an hour that makes it
a category one but doesn't but don't
underestimate the power of this storm
rising water has flooded several coastal
cities swamp and businesses there are
reports of around 150 people still
needing rescue in New Bern North
Carolina more than 320 thousand homes
and businesses across the region have
lost power we have a team of
correspondents covering the storm CBS
Evening News anchor Jeff Glor leads our
coverage from Wilmington North Carolina
Florence began to bring its full force
to North Carolina overnight
lashing the coast was stinging rain
forceful wind and flooding in Belhaven a
rising river nearly swallowed the first
floor of this house as waves crashed
against its windows the lights were on
it is not clear if anyone was home one
of the hardest hit areas so far is
Newburgh where this morning around 150
people awaited rescue after more than 10
feet of powerful storm surge flooded the
town earlier as the storm slowly churned
toward Shore people who chose not to
evacuate got caught in floodwaters they
tried desperately to return to their
homes as the Neuse River overflowed
video taken Thursday night shows the
damage from wind gusts topping 100 miles
an hour they were strong enough to tear
the roofs and facades off stores and
destroy gas stations
in Moorhead City all that's left of this
building is a pile of crumbled wood much
of the wind damage was done even before
the storm surge there poured into the
streets this school in Jacksonville
suffered significant damage inside as
the panel's tore from the ceiling and
water rained down inside classrooms and
in Wilmington hurricane-force winds blew
transformers putting much of the city in
darkness